hey guys today it is the 12th of January
my name is Jess McDonald and you are
watching dreams yay has announced a new
service for PC which is going to act
much like EA access does for Xbox one
origin access which is available now in
some regions will give subscribers
access to a range of PC games for
monthly fee that monthly fee is four
dollars 99 in the US and Canada and 399
pounds and 399 euro in the UK and
Germany respectively the service has
launched with 15 games in turtle but
this list is expected to grow this time
the publisher have said origin access
brings players endless gaming with a
growing collection of great pc games
much like EA access new a EA titles will
also appear on our can access before
they made available to the public check
out our story on gamespot for the full
list of games included in the service
valve has sent out a memo to developers
later obtained by steam DB which notes
the overwhelming success of the steam
winter sale valve have guessed that part
of the reason the sale was successful
was due to the elimination of daily and
flash sale which offered an even bigger
discount on games for a limited time
they explained our hypothesis was that
this new format would be a better way to
serve customers that may only be able to
visit steam once or twice during the 13
day event we also saw this change as an
opportunity to showcase a deeper variety
of titles to customers each day while
having confidence that any game being
highlighted would be at its lowest
discount they added that the offer of a
free steam trading card to users who
scan through their discovery cube proved
fruitful and reported a one hundred
ninety-seven percent increase in the
rate of wishlist additions during a sale
a number of which were subsequently
purchased My Lai shun fontina who you
may recognize as the human embodiment of
GTA 5's Franklin Clinton may have hinted
at single player DLC for the game he
posted up a picture of himself on
Instagram kitted out in a mo cap suit
with in rough
as offices above the caption that read
Lola with an extended ellipsis sad
picture and extended ellipsis combo may
allude to the fact that 14 0 is in the
studio providing new acting work the GTA
5's long-awaited single player expansion
that said fontina doesn't clarify when
the picture was taken and the similar
photo was posted up in June of last year
so we could be jumping the gun with bad
gas let me know down in the comments if
you splurged on the latest steam sale
and what you picked up you can add the
game spot we've got stories on the
Psychonauts 2 crowdfunding campaign and
a Pokemon 3d s bundle that is everything
I have you today as always let me know
what you cared about and I will catch
the same time tomorrow